what would it mean to win tonight it's
such a subjective thing this time of the
year we all get to come together see we
don't see each other all year we all go
off in foreign lands and make these
things and we had to come together and
say hey I really liked your work and
after that it's been a big year for Brad
Pitt it's what a year for you to
fabulous pieces of cinema will you be
done after this for the year I get to
put it away yes get on to other things
making some new things reading scripts
keep making yeah
the a-list star released two critically
acclaimed movies back to back I do what
I do because of my dad
she gave his life through the pursuit of
knowledge
because up there is where our story's
gonna be told at Astro which debuted in
August at the Venice Film Festival it
was pretty special and of course once
upon a time in Hollywood which premiered
at the Cannes Film Festival in May
did you know you broke the Internet okay
mr. net speak for you're doing good babe
sure fans couldn't stop talking about
the 56 year old sexy shirtless roof
scene and what's got you so upset man
but it was his performance alongside
Leonardo DiCaprio that quickly gained
him some serious awards buzz tell me
about working with Leo he's a good egg
you know we come from the same circle
I really admire his taste and his
choices and I'm really happy this one
lined up for us one of the best tantrums
ever laid down on film I'm just gonna
leave it at that
you and Brad your chemistry in this
movie is next-level it's so special how
did you guys just make that magic
actually you know it really came
naturally and it was one of the more
easy sort of natural fits that I think
I've ever experienced the role earned
Brad Best Supporting Actor nods at the
Critics Choice Awards Screen Actors
Guild Awards Golden Globes and the
Academy Awards and if that weren't
enough brats production company Plan B
will be honored with the David Selznick
Achievement Award at the producers guild
awards Brad has been nominated for an
Oscar five times in the past I'm pretty
grateful for that
in 2014 he took home his first and only
Academy Award for 12 years a slave a
film he produced this is a film that
will that has legs that will that will
be around and be speaking to people for
for many many years and and that's the
biggest prize but no matter what happens
at this year's Oscars Brad is taking it
all in stride do you ever like worry
the next thing no no no I mean I feel
pretty privileged and and you know it's
necessarily fun this thing hopefully we
have other things going for us there's
no shelf life on you Brad Pitt because
you're on top of the roof fixing the
satellite TV in a little sure let's see
yeah
they probably clean that one up I don't
know
thank you though
[Music]